this morning we're getting an inside
look we're switching gears here a little
bit speaking of bicycle metaphors -
we're getting an inside look at an
unprecedented coronavirus study a tiny
town near Venice Italy has become a
living laboratory
it's where the country's first
coronavirus victim was from sixty and
six correspondent Seth Doane shows us
how the town immediately sealed itself
off and has tested nearly everyone for
cove at 19 at least three times sixty
and six features 60-minute style
storytelling in around six minute
episodes it airs on the streaming app
kwibi and is produced by CBS News which
is part of Viacom CBS and investor in
kwibi
take a look wincing their way through
test after test nearly every resident in
this town of 3,300 is voluntarily
enduring a little discomfort to take
part in something unprecedented I think
was an incredible testimony of trust in
science in society the soft-spoken
virologist dr. Andrea croissant EEP has
become an unlikely hero here since he
started studying the town of Voe what's
unique here is that dr. Kazan T has been
testing those residents for kovat 19
repeatedly since the beginning of the
epidemic he says this is the most
well-studied community in the world and
Seth Doane joins us now from from Rome
good morning Seth the three tests per
per citizen of that city is really
remarkable
what can we learn from Bo really
remarkable and Anthony a little
uncomfortable as you can see those
peoples kind of wincing but we've
learned a remarkable amount from from
this small town of about 3,000 people
there are concrete scientific findings
one of the early ones this death the
Adriano Trevisan died February 21st with
set into motion what wound up being this
kind of grand experiment so if you think
back early February this was very early
on and one of the first things they
discovered was just how many more people
had the coronavirus than they initially
thought and how many of those people
were asymptomatic
then this neurologist who you just we
just saw in in the clip doctor and Greg
the Xanthi he had been on sabbatical
turns out he's on sabbatical from London
near this place where there's this huge
outbreak in this in this pandemic and he
says wow you've created a fantastic
really fascinating setting here where
you've tested a cross-section of a
population could we go in there and give
all of these people who have now locked
down the military came they closed the
borders no one was allowed in and out
they said okay look this place is in
essence frozen in time could we please
do another test and go back the guy who
runs Veneto region Luca Ziya said you're
just as crazy as I am trying to test all
these people again but they found the
test the test was something that the
folks in town were willing to do again
and they've done it again so I can't
tell you everything they found but
they've given a blood test you have to
watch the piece but they're finding
remarkable things about antibodies and
they're trying to build a genetic map of
this town now because they know the
transmission chain though was locked
down Seth abut about two weeks before
the rest of the country I mean can you
give us first of all how are they able
to test everybody three times well they
said they they actively Chris Anthes lab
at the University of Padua which is one
of the most prestigious institutions has
a robust hospital there they are now
able to do around 5,000 tests a day so
one of the interesting things we
actually don't talk about in the story
business or just wasn't time was he
before we went in to vote and before we
met him and came into the lab he said I
want you all you and your crew the
people a camera crew that I was with to
also be tested we've got to be very
careful about transmission and who comes
and who goes we were all negative and we
tested again coming out so he has
frankly the capability to do these tests
and he said let's raise the money to do
this again and we'll ask for volunteers
and nearly everyone in town turned out
for all of these tests and the most
interesting one in many ways was the
third test which not only was a co vid
test that that swab that you see that
uncomfortable swab but also a blood test
to check for antibodies and to build
this genetic map and even kids turned
out for this for this blood test Italy
has dramatically decreased the number of
case
to what degree did vote play a role in
sort of the way the country responded
well in many ways Anthony this was a
model it's been written up even in the
Landsat a very prestigious Medical
Journal the approach there Invo was
directed by this luca Ziya from the
far-right league party who has some
scientific background he's studied
medicine he said you know I'm not a
doctor but I did study viruses and I
know you have to isolate viruses to
fight them so they were very good at
locking down and testing and compared
with lumber T which looked much more at
strengthening hospitals the the approach
of testing in veneto worked all right
Seth Doane in Rome for us this morning
said thank you very much
you can watch Seth's 60 in 6 story today
on the mobile streaming app kwibi